[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
journal de la saison sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 4 septembre
c'était la rentrée ce matin pour plus de
trois cent cinq mille élèves
yves binois moment toujours important
pour les enfants et les parents et nous
parlons de cette journée et des
nouveautés avec notre invité serge
clément directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale des
yvelines l'une des nouveautés pour cette
rentrée la mise en place bien sûr des
classes de cp à 12 élèves dans les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
renforcée c'est notamment le cas à
l'école élémentaire henri wallon de
trappes où la députée nadia s s'est
rendu ce matin à la fin de ce journal du
sport et déjà une déception pour un club
du département et handballeurs de
plaisir quitte la coupe de france
défaite hier à domicile face à issy mais
avant de développer ses titres
l'ouverture cet après midi d'un procès
au tribunal correctionnel de versailles
celui de deux militants de l'association
de défense animale l214 jugée pour
violation de domicile et tentative
d'atteinte à la vie privée d'autrui en
décembre 2016 il s'était introduit
clandestinement avec des caméras dans
l'abattoir et guillard ont deux ou dans
les images filmées montraient la mise à
mort violente de porc lait le procès
initialement prévu en juin avait été
reportée en raison du dépôt tardif d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
le retour à l'école pour quelques 300
5623 élèves des yvelines ce matin il
faisait alors entrer après deux mois de
vacances et de repos afin de bien
recharger les batteries
comment s'est déroulée la première
matinée de cours micros tendus aux
enfants saint quentinois par mélanie
poquet et axel d'eau est belle ce matin
à la sortie des classes à 11h30 s'est
assez bien passé
tu as fait quoi ce matin j'ai
[Musique]
j'ai fait je fais une pige d'exercice
c'était vraiment bien s'amuser on a
retrouvé nos amis et on a commencé à
parler ce qu'on a fait pendant les
vacances et tout le temps elle était
passée trop vite on a dit comment ce
qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant les
vacances
tu avais un peu peur ce matin oui alors
pourquoi tu avais pas je connais pas des
bus pleins rassurer la rentrée vous les
vues moment d'émotion a pour ces jeunes
vivent les noirs on accueille sur ce
plateau pour parler de la rentrée à
notre premier invité serge clément
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
académique des services de l'éducation
nationale des yvelines alors gelé
précisé juste avant ce micro-trottoir
305 milles un peu plus de 305 milles et
l'avesnois ont fait leur rentrée
aujourd'hui et où vont le faire
d'ailleurs tout au long de cette semaine
et est ce que cette première journée
s'est bien passée
est ce qu'il ya des accros à déplorer je
vais reprendre les propos de l'ena tout
s'est bien passé
les choses sont particulièrement bien
lancé tout simplement parce qu'elles ont
été parfaitement préparée par les
services avec toujours ce souci d'être
au plus près des besoins de nos enfants
sur tout le département
et aujourd'hui je peux considérer que de
cette rentrée cette année scolaire est
particulièrement bien engagée bien
préparée par vos services on va
d'ailleurs aborder un les quelques
nouveautés elles sont même nombreuses 1
pour cette rentrée
comment s'annonce du coup cette année
cette nouvelle année 2017 2018 si une
année qui est une année enthousiasmante
nous nous continuons à travailler
notamment en ayant une taille tout à
fait particulier en direction des élèves
qui sont les plus fragiles dans notre
département j'ai l'habitude de dire que
c'est un département qui fait bien
réussir ses élèves
mais nous avons encore à travailler pour
ceux qui d'entre eux ne réussissent pas
à l'école ont des difficultés avec un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui
s'enrichissent à la rentrée nous allons
y revenir
ensemble et le département est organisée
justement pour amener davantage d'entre
eux à la réussite que ce soit avec les
cp des doublés ou avec un travail
beaucoup plus approfondie encore en
faveur des élèves que l'on dit à besoins
éducatifs particuliers notamment les
élèves porteurs de handicap avant de
voir le premier sujet a préparé par
notre rédaction est ce qu'il ya eu des
des soucis au niveau des contrats aidés
on sait que le gouvernement a annoncé la
suppression de beaucoup de ces emplois
qui les communes les voilà les communes
les utilise notamment pour employer le
personnel de cantine je pense au
personnel de cantine est ce que il ya
déjà eu des mouvements de grèves ou des
grèves sont annoncées pour cette semaine
alors dans le dans l'éducation nationale
nous n'avons pas de problématique de ce
type nous sommes extrêmement vigilants
vous imaginez bien pour ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement des élèves porteurs de
handicap je veux rassurer les familles
et leur dire que cette priorité
parfaitement respecté nous avons
aujourd'hui plus de 2000 assistants de
vie scolaire qui travaille auprès de ces
jeunes ce mouvement va s'amplifier et
nous avons bien évidemment comme
préoccupation d'accompagner les
personnels qui sortirait de ce
dispositif est de leur offrir avec
d'autres notamment pôle emploi d'autres
perspectives plus durable de manière à
ce qu'ils puissent s'engager sur
d'autres fonctions du cas échéant
alors en ce début de journal ont parlé
des élèves côté enseignants plus de
30000 ont fait leur prérentrée dans les
yvelines dès la semaine dernière par
milieu des petits nouveaux dans le
département ils sont 300 professeurs
stagiaires cette année et véronique
daniel ancien militaire a choisi de se
reconvertir dans le métier et mélanie
poquet a suivi ses premiers pas pendant
un an
véronique va partager son temps entre
ses 23 élèves de ce1 et sa formation de
professeur des écoles
pour elle c'est une nouvelle carrière
j'ai été pendant sept ans officier dans
l'armée de l'air
j'ai occupé plusieurs postes dont le
poste professeur d'anglais donc j'ai une
expérience du face à face pédagogique
mais
avec dédé
des adultes donc ce qui est très
différent une seconde expérience avec
des cm1 dans une école privée en
nouvelle calédonie la conforte dans son
idée
elle veut enseigner a déçu de mes études
je voulais devenir enseignante
j'ai choisi les langues de prime abord
mais j'ai toujours eu dans un coin de la
tête l'idée de devenir maîtresse et
voilà l'opportunité s'est offerte à moi
de pouvoir
me reconvertir et donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion pour passer le concours
préparé pendant un an et
et donc voilà on a toutes les chances de
mon côté pour être là aujourd'hui
dans ma classe à guyancourt ce lundi la
voilà dans le grand bain derniers
préparatifs
accueil appel des élèves et premier
cours une réaction peut-être sur ce
sujet serge clément l'a vu une jeune
professeur reconverti pour le coup on le
voit une reconversion est tout à fait
possible dans le monde de l'enseignement
on peut se reconvertir facilement très
très beau sujet que le vôtre vous savez
que les il y n'y échappe pas nous avons
un besoin de renouvellement de nos
professeurs et la question du
recrutement de ses professeurs est
extrêmement importante et on s'aperçoit
moi qui préside le concours de
professeur des écoles que nombre de nos
candidats viennent évidemment de l'esp
et alexis fm ont une formation
pédagogique et d'autres candidats de
plus en plus nombreux et qui réussissent
fort bien d'ailleurs à ce concours ont
déjà une expérience professionnelle
qu'ils peuvent réinvestir dans un
nouveau métier en étant accompagné parce
que la formation est un axe fort pour
nous et je suis très très heureux moi de
deux de vous dire que le dernier
concours de professeur des écoles était
un concours de très très haute valeur
avec une moyenne des candidats admis
entendait bien plus de 1600 lauréats du
concours 950 un bon cru 2010 est avec
plus de 14 de moyenne sur 4 épreuves
extrêmement exigeante donc ça c'est
vraiment extrêmement enthousiasmant de
voir cet engagement à la fois de ceux
qui viennent de l'espé et d'autres qui
ont compris que l'enseignement était un
beau métier
du coup comment va se dérouler cette
année pour les professeurs stagiaires là
ils viennent d'obtenir leur diplôme
vient d'obtenir leur diplôme ils sont
dans une logique d'alternance est à dire
qu avec l'esp et nous travaillons à la
fois sur le terrain ils vont être
accompagnés par des professionnels
aguerris et en même temps ils vont
continuer leur formation scientifique et
pédagogique au sein de l'espé en tirant
parti de cette expérience
professionnelle et de manière à
consolider tous ses acquis voire même à
les développer et à être en pleine
responsabilité l'année prochaine puisque
je rappelle que cette année ils n'ont
que la moitié d'un temps en
responsabilité devant la classe
très bien alors beaucoup de chiffres on
l'a vu dans ce début du journal on vous
donne ces chiffres sur la rentrée le
recteur de l'académie de versailles
daniel filâtre a d'ailleurs donné une
conférence de presse vendredi dernier
l'occasion de présenter les moyens et
les effectifs de cette rentrée scolaire
2010 sept reportages de mélanie poker et
nicolas landry des moyens
supplémentaires pour cette nouvelle
année scolaire 550 postes ont été créés
dans le premier degré de l'académie de
versailles mais 110 emplois dans les
lycées et collèges
nous avons accueilli les jeunes
professeurs mais il peut manquer
évidemment ici et là il manquera
certainement ici et là je serai rassurée
là encore les familles ou les équipes
dans les collèges et des lycées tout le
rectorat est mobilisé dans le second
degré 65 mille cinq cents élèves sont
rentrés dans les 130 collège des
yvelines mise en oeuvre à la rentrée
2016 la réforme des collèges est
assouplie objectif donner plus
d'initiatives aux établissements des
projets pédagogiques qui vont s'opérer
au 6e en réseau notamment en éducation
prioritaire puisque nous sommes à
versailles je vais penser au secteur de
manteaux secteur de trappes comment
l'ensemble des collèges ont un projet
projet linguistique projet culturel avec
leurs élèves pour le premier degré plus
de 149 mille élèves sont accueillis dans
les neuf cent soixante douze écoles
maternelles et primaires yvelinoise
principal changement en élémentaire le
retour à la semaine des quatre jours
près de 57 % des communes du département
ont décidé de revenir sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
à noter aussi 5 réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcée des yvelines vont
bénéficier du dispositif de classe de cp
à 12 élèves et comme pour chaque rentrée
plusieurs élus ont fait le déplacement
dans les établissements est la députée
elle est reine de la 11e circonscription
des îles
li na dia s'est elle rendue à trappes à
l'école élémentaire henri wallon là où a
été mise en place une classe de cp à 12
élèves c'est l'une des décisions phares
du président de la république
emmanuel macron dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire renforcer 85 %
des effectifs de serre et plus sont
concernés par cette nouveauté dans le
département la mesure primordiale pour
l'acquisition des bases à l'école
d'après nadia et je vous propose de
l'écouter au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch les petites classes comme
le cp et les ce1 sont des classes où il
est important d'acquérir les
fondamentaux donc les trois fondamentaux
de savoir lire écrire et compter
aujourd'hui enfin jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
s'est aperçu que bon nombre d'élèves ne
maîtrisez pas ses fondamentaux à leur
entrée au collège
donc il est important de leur donner les
bases des les plus petites classes et
donc le dédoublement des classes dans
des zones prioritaires comme celle ci
est important aujourd'hui serge clément
grande mesure de cette rentrée donc la
mise en place de ces classes de cp à 12
élèves dans les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire renforcer concrètement
comment comment ça s'est mis en place
comment ça fonctionne
d'abord une très forte mobilisation des
équipes pédagogiques auprès des
inspecteurs de circonscription concernée
une réflexion qui va prolonger celle que
l'on a engagé il y a déjà quelques
années de manière à être capable de
mieux traiter la difficulté scolaire au
début de l'école élémentaire qui est
l'école obligatoire et nous allons
développer notamment des outils ceux qui
vont être acheminées très prochainement
dans les écoles pour permettre par
exemple aux professeurs de faire passer
des évaluations dès le début de cp de
manière à bien identifier ce qui fait
problème quelles sont les difficultés
des élèves puisque chacun peut avoir à
la fois ses forces et ressources mais
aussi ses ces problèmes et de façon donc
à faire ce travail d'individualisation
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
puisque plus de 9
cp dans le département sur 10 seront
dédoublés les autres seront co animé
avec deux enseignants paris donnera deux
enseignants par classe mais c'est une
mesure qui est posée systématiquement
dans tous les cp des drm plus avec
encore une fois un accompagnement et une
formation et surtout une confiance au
terrain il faut vraiment j'étais ce
matin avec des
des professeurs et je leur ai dit
combien avec monsieur le recteur nous
comptions sur eux combien nous leur
faisions confiance et combien cette
question de l'audace d'oser était
extrêmement importante et ils ont tout
loisir d'expérimenter dernière chose de
très rapides serge clément quel est le
calendrier sur surface et c'est
l'expérimentation de ces classes à 12
cette expérimentation de la dizaine de
jours qui vient les les documents
d'évaluation seront acheminés et nous
rencontreront régulièrement les équipes
ne leur permettront de se réunir nous
ferons des évaluations régulières du
dispositif mais pour permettre aux uns
et aux autres de mutualiser le travail
qu'ils réalisent et continuer à
s'enrichir mutuellement
merci serge qu'elle gère clément pardon
d'avoir été sur ce plateau qui je le
rappelle directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale des
yvelines est la rentrée rime également
avec fournitures scolaires c'est la
course entre l achat des stylos feuilles
ou encore chaussures de sport les
parents croule sous les demandes des
enfants est du stress supplémentaire au
moment de reprendre l'école ni quel
ennemi d'euros et nicolas kirillovitch
que ce soit les surlignant pour la
terminale l'agenda pour le collège ou
tout simplement le choix du cahier pour
l'année scolaire l'achat des fournitures
est un moment particulier à l'heure de
la rentrée parents des enfants doivent
parfois régler des équations surprise
moi je suis en temps de choisir une
calculatrice sachant que le lycée m'a
donné le choix entre deux et je découvre
avec stupéfaction qui a 25 euros d'écart
entre les deux donc
apprêtée je vais regarder qu'est ce que
je peux avoir de plus ou de moins pour
25 euros
voilà 25 euros qui peuvent peser cher
cette année le panier moyen des
fournitures scolaires et de 80,2 euros
pour le cours préparatoire 186e est un
peu moins de 200 euros pour l'entrée au
lycée des sommes conséquentes qu'il faut
budgétisé juste après les vacances alors
les plaisirs non non pas de plaisir non
non parce qu'on a pas les moyens
j'essaye de faire moitié moitié c'est à
dire lui faire prendre des choses qui
sont suffisamment fantaisistes pour lui
faire plaisir tout en n'étant pas les
plus chers pour pouvoir épargner mon
budget du côté des distributeurs aussi
cette dernière ligne droite de la
rentrée est un moment crucial
cette enseigne spécialisée dans la vente
de fournitures scolaires réalise 20% de
son chiffre d'affaires entre mi-août et
fin septembre habituellement au long de
l'année avec nos professionnels et aux
particuliers ont fait environ 250 300
clients par jour donc on double activité
durant la période des classes ont
recruté en fonction on prend 2,3
personnes supplémentaires pour le
magasin notamment pour réaliser l'équipe
de rentrée des classes que les gens
déposent il chercher deux heures après
et pour assurer surtout en caisse pour
que le volume puisse puisse passer
facilement et la course dans les rayons
ne devrait pas s'arrêter cette semaine
avec les demandes de matériel qui
varient en fonction des professeurs et
des matières c'est une réalité pour les
néo bacheliers et pour les autres jeunes
d'ailleurs la rentrée ne fait pas le
bonheur de tout le monde certains sont
perdues dont d'autres n'ont tout
simplement pas d'affectation ou de
formation pour cette rentrée et pour
aider les 15 25 ans le pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux propose le
dispositif sos rentrée c'est jusqu'au 29
septembre pour en parler deuxième invité
avec moi sur ce plateau stéphanie gareau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la responsable
du pôle jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux
première question pourquoi mettre en
place ce dispositif je rappelle sos
rentrée
en fait ce dispositif permet à certains
jeunes qui se retrouvent sans solution à
la rentrée de pouvoir rebondir assez
rapidement plutôt que de perdre toute
leur année alors pour certains ça va
être simplement les réguliers vers des
partenaires compétents suivant leurs
besoins
et puis pour d'autres c'est un
accompagnement plus dans la méthode
donc chaque année on a cette période des
jeunes qui qui viennent nous voir parce
qu'ils recherchent souvent par exemple
une entreprise pour un stage en
alternance une alternance et c'est très
difficile de trouver une entreprise et
donc à cette période de l'année il faut
vraiment redoubler les efforts et on les
accompagne surtout sur le
le travail sur la candidature cv lettre
de motivation et aussi comment on fait
une relance
comment se présente en entretien et sert
à céder des astuces aussi qu'ils vont
finir par payer et vous le disais alors
il n'y a pas une équipe ça va être au
cas par cas selon les besoins du jeune
au cas par cas et souvent oriente vers
des partenaires cio mission locale
suivant le besoin
et puis pour certains ça va être
chercher leur premier emploi ou faire
une pause dans leurs études parce qu'ils
n'ont pas trop de projets donc
effectivement on essaie de voir quel est
le besoin et on accompagne le jeune
individuellement sans rendez vous pour
essayer de trouver une solution ensemble
stéphanie gars on a l'impression que
l'orientation ça rime souvent avec un
casse tête pourquoi c'est si difficile
de s'orienter ce que c'est difficile de
s'orienter
je dirais il ya une majorité de jeunes
qui heureusement trouvent leur voie où
on déjà une affectation pour la rentrée
mais pour d'autres
l'été étant passé ça devient urgent de
trouver une solution un point de repli
si ça n'a pas fonctionné et souvent
malgré toutes les informations dont on a
accès aujourd'hui
l'accompagnement est important alors on
l'a dit dispositif sos rentrée jusqu'au
29 septembre
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
un jeune va venir vous voir au pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux qui
sait dans quel outil vont être mises à
disposition pour lui alors bien sûr une
écoute et un accompagnement individuel
par un informateur jeunesse et ensuite
on a des outils test d'orientation basé
sur les aptitudes et c'est pour libérer
un petit peu le jeune ne pas se braquer
sur des résultats mais plus chercher un
projet qui lui ressemble
après des modèles de cv lettres de
motivation quand retravaillent ensemble
des simulations d'entretiens avec des
entreprises ou des organismes de
formation tout dépend du besoin cet
oncle à dire un suivi individualisé
on l'a dit un dispositif qui s'adresse
aux 18 25 ans et à tous les 18 25 ans ça
s'adresse à certaines personnes
même avant 18 ans j'aurai des quinze ans
pour ceux qui cherchent un apprentissage
à la sortie de la troisième
donc tous les jeunes parce que nous sur
le pôle jeunesse on propose un accueil
individuel et anonymes dont tous les
jeunes
de mentir
de 51 peuvent venir nous trouver sans
rendez vous du lundi au vendredi et
déjà nous appeler pour avoir des
désinformations s'ils le souhaitent au
01 30 57 42 40
le numéro d'ailleurs sa fiche pour ceux
qui nous regardent à l'antenne merci
stéphanie gareau du pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux je rappelle les
informations sos rentrée est proposée
jusqu'au 29 septembre et plus d'infos
donc au numéro de téléphone qui
s'affiche une visite ministérielle dans
le département pour boucler ce grand
dossier rentrée ce matin le lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école a reçu à
la secrétaire d'état auprès auprès du
ministère des armées
geneviève darrieussecq l'établissement
en a profité pour faire découvrir sa
nouvelle formation en bts sur la cyber
défense
le point avec camille lambert une
première depuis 50 ans les 700 élèves du
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école on
tue une rentrée un peu particulière
lundi 4 septembre geneviève darrieussecq
secrétaire d'état en charge des armées
est venu découvrir l'établissement le
lycée n'avait pas reçu de visite
ministérielle depuis 1966 une manière
générale la formation l'enseignement est
essentielle dans notre pays et que
l'enseignement militaire à toute sa part
ne se rendent pas compte suffisamment
peut-être dans le civil de l'importance
que l'armée apporte à la formation de la
jeunesse
c'est une de leurs priorités il le fonds
avait beaucoup de savoir-faire lycée
mais aussi prépas aux grandes écoles
l'établissement a développé son
enseignement supérieur
nouveauté de cette rentrée en bts
systèmes numériques option informatique
orientée sur la cyber défense c'est le
premier de ce type en france
ces 34 élèves deviendront des
techniciens capables de contrer les
cyber attaques
comment justement lutter différents
moyens techniques pour que vous
connaissez vous avez entendu parler des
pare-feu des antivirus des et les
systèmes encore plus technique plus
technique je dirais plus sophistiqués
pour justement détecter ces attaques
et puis
les stopper et puis ensuite aussi signer
les identifier parce que savoir qui est
derrière ces attaques
donc tout cela c'est c'est un métier
nous avons du retard en général et dans
le monde civil en particulier ou
n'importe quelle entreprise ou n'importe
quel smartphone est pas à l'abri d'une
attaque virale dont nous avons besoin de
jeunes formés dans ce domaine là la
visite de la secrétaire d'état s'est
terminée par un discours devant
l'ensemble de l'établissement
le premier d'une longue série pour
geneviève darrieussecq dans les
prochains mois elle prévoit de visiter
tous les lycées militaires du pays
vigilance pour les habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines des algues toxiques
ont pu se développer au bassin de la
sourderie à montigny le bretonneux
en attendant le résultat des analyses
quelques précautions sont à prendre
l'agglomération recommande d'éviter tout
contact avec l'eau et de tenir les
chiens en laisse
à proximité il est conseillé d'adopter
les mêmes réflexes pour les autres
bassins étant du territoire le sport ce
week end on jouait le premier tour de la
coupe de france de handball l'équipe
senior de plaisir recevait ici dans un
gymnase nicholl nicholl hasler bouillant
une ambiance ce qui n'a pas permis aux
plaisirs wa de se qualifier pour le
prochain tour reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et yves opstaan berger le
plaisir handball club faisait sa rentrée
avec un match de coupe de france les
plaisirs wa promu cette saison en
nationale iii recevait ce dimanche 3
septembre au gymnase nicholas lard le
club d'ici équipe habituée à jouer dans
cette division
une équipe réellement profil des équipes
de nationale 3 à savoir des joueurs avec
un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de jeu cette équipe
avec voilà nos qualités sur le terrain
la différence d'expérience ne s'est pas
fait ressentir au coude à coude pendant
toute la rencontre le match s'est
terminé sur un score de parité 24
partout à la fin du temps réglementaire
des genres donc dû se départager par une
terrible séance de tirs au but dans
cette loterie c'est finalement ici qui
l'emportent 28 à 27 plaisir est éliminée
de cette coupe de france
le scénario du match a été fou les deux
équipes où leurs temps forts il est on
était devant ils sont remontés à la fin
quand je voulais dire une minute de la
fin on est mené de deux buts et on se
retrouve à égalité donc c'est vraiment
un scénario fou qui donne pleins de
promesses pour la saison à venir pour
notre équipe
on a essayé de tout faire pour pour
jouer jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la fin on
est joueur parce qu'on continue à être
agressif et à aucun moment
on joue petit bras pour plaisir le
championnat de nationale 3 commencera
officiellement le 17 septembre prochain
avec la réception du club de massy eux
ont connu la victoire hier les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux se sont
qualifiés pour les demi finales de la
division 1 le championnat de france de
baseball succès lors du match 3 à
l'extérieur contre le paris université
club score de 15 à 5
dernier rempart et pas des moindres
avant la finale rouen qui a terminé en
tête de la saison régulière match 1 ce
samedi à montigny le bretonneux et pour
refermer ce journal un événement festif
à versailles le deuxième bal folk des
colibris l'association écologiste il
s'est tenu samedi à la salle marcel
tassencourt environ 150 personnes y ont
participé
un esprit de partage et de convivialité
pour cette soirée sensibilisation sur le
tri repas écolo et bien sûr de la danse
étaient au programme
l'idée c'est que c'est très inclusif et
ça c'est vraiment l'esprit des colibris
c'est de permettre à tout le monde de
pouvoir participer tout le monde peut
voir danser et donc ça c'est le vraiment
la chose qui me paraissaient importantes
par rapport à des bals de tango de
rhodes salsa là c'est quelque chose où
on peut d'abord dansé un groupe
et même si on sait pas du tout danser on
peut parfaitement
ben s'intégrer et puis danser et faire
plaisir ces bals folks des colibris de
versailles vont être désormais plus
régulier se tiendront chaque semestre
prochain rendez vous le 23 novembre à la
maison de quartier de porchefontaine
c'est la fin de ce premier journal de la
saison sur tb 78 retrouvez tous nos
reportages sur notre site internet et
sur l'application mobile tv
soixante dix huit bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]